and to lumber that data back to the cloud and make better diagnostics?
In fact, the whole era of laboratory medicine
is completely changing.
We can now leverage microfluidics,
like this chip made by Steve Quake at Stanford.
Microfluidics can replace an entire lab of technicians;
put it on a chip, enable thousands of tests at the point of care,
anywhere in the world.
This will really leverage technology to the rural and the underserved
and enable what used to be thousand-dollar tests to be done for pennies,
and at the point of care.
If we go down the small pathway a little bit further,
we're entering the era of nanomedicine,
the ability to make devices super-small,
to the point where we can design red blood cells
or microrobots that monitor our blood system or immune system,
or even those that might clear out the clots from our arteries.
Now how about exponentially cheaper?
Not something we usually think about in the era of medicine,
but hard disks used to be 3,400 dollars for 10 megabytes -- exponentially cheaper.
In genomics now, the genome cost about a billion dollars
about 10 years ago, when the first one came out.
We're now approaching essentially a $1,000 genome, probably next year.
And in two years, a $100 genome.
What will we do with $100 genomes?
Soon we'll have millions of these tests available.
Then it gets interesting, when we start to crowd-source that information,
and enter the era of true personalized medicine:
the right drug for the right person at the right time,
instead of what we're doing now, which is the same drug for everybody,
blockbuster drug medications, which don't work for the individual.
Many different companies are working on leveraging these approaches.
I'll show you a simple example, from 23andMe again.
My data indicates I've got about average risk
for developing macular degeneration, a kind of blindness.
But if I take that same data, upload it to deCODEme,
I can look at my risk for type 2 diabetes; I'm at almost twice the risk.
I might want to watch how much dessert I have at lunch, for example.
It might change my behavior.
Leveraging my knowledge of my pharmacogenomics:
how my genes modulate, what my drugs do and what doses I need
will become increasingly important,
and once in the hands of individuals and patients,
will make better drug dosing and selection available.
So again, it's not just genes, it's multiple details --
our habits, our environmental exposures.
When was the last time your doctor asked where you've lived?
Geomedicine: where you live, what you've been exposed to,
can dramatically affect your health.
We can capture that information.
Genomics, proteomics, the environment --
all this data streaming at us individually and as physicians:
How do we manage it?
We're now entering the era of systems medicine, systems biology,
where we can start to integrate all this information.
And by looking at the patterns, for example, in our blood,
of 10,000 biomarkers in a single test,
we can look at patterns and detect disease at a much earlier stage.
This is called by Lee Hood, the father of the field, P4 Medicine.
We'll be predictive and know what you're likely to have.
We can be preventative; that prevention can be personalized.
More importantly, it'll be increasingly participatory.
Through websites like PatientsLikeMe
or managing your data on Microsoft HealthVault or Google Health,
leveraging this together in participatory ways
will be increasingly important.
I'll finish up with exponentially better.
We'd like to get therapies better and more effective.
Today we treat high blood pressure mostly with pills.
What if we take a new device,
knock out the nerve vessels that help mediate blood pressure,
and in a single therapy, basically cure hypertension?
This is a new device doing essentially that.
It should be on the market in a year or two.
How about more targeted therapies for cancer?
I'm an oncologist and know that most of what we give is essentially poison.
We learned at Stanford and other places that we can discover cancer stem cells,
the ones that seem to be really responsible for disease relapse.
So if you think of cancer as a weed,
we often can whack the weed away and it seems to shrink,
but it often comes back.
So we're attacking the wrong target.
The cancer stem cells remain,
and the tumor can return months or years later.
We're now learning to identify the cancer stem cells
and identify those as targets and go for the long-term cure.
We're entering the era of personalized oncology,
the ability to leverage all of this data together,
analyze the tumor
and come up with a real, specific cocktail for the individual patient.
I'll close with regenerative medicine.
I've studied a lot about stem cells.
Embryonic stem cells are particularly powerful.
We have adult stem cells throughout our body;
we use those in bone marrow transplantation.
Geron, last year, started the first trial using human embryonic stem cells
to treat spinal cord injuries.
Still a phase I trial, but evolving.
We've been using adult stem cells in clinical trials for about 15 years
to approach a whole range of topics, particularly cardiovascular disease.
If we take our own bone marrow cells and treat a patient with a heart attack,
we can see much improved heart function and better survival
using our own bone marrow derived cells after a heart attack.
I invented a device called the MarrowMiner,
a much less invasive way for harvesting bone marrow.
It's now been FDA approved; hopefully on the market in the next year.
Hopefully you can appreciate the device
going through the patient's body removing bone marrow, not with 200 punctures,
but with a single puncture, under local anesthesia.
Where is stem-cell therapy going?
If you think about it,
every cell in your body has the same DNA you had when you were an embryo.
We can now reprogram your skin cells
to actually act like a pluripotent embryonic stem cell
and utilize those, potentially, to treat multiple organs in the same patient,
making personalized stem cell lines.
I think there'll be a new era of your own stem cell banking
to have in the freezer your own cardiac cells, myocytes and neural cells
to use them in the future, should you need them.
We're integrating this now with a whole era of cellular engineering,
and integrating exponential technologies for essentially 3D organ printing,
replacing the ink with cells,
and essentially building and reconstructing a 3D organ.
That's where things are heading.
Still very early days,
but I think, as integration of exponential technologies,
this is the example.
So in closing, as you think about technology trends
and how to impact health and medicine,
we're entering an era of miniaturization,
decentralization and personalization.
And by pulling these things together,
if we start to think about how to understand and leverage them,
we're going to empower the patient, enable the doctor, enhance wellness
and begin to cure the well before they get sick.
Because I know as a doctor, if someone comes to me with stage I disease,
I'm thrilled; we can often cure them.
But often it's too late,
and it's stage III or IV cancer, for example.
So by leveraging these technologies together,
I think we'll enter a new era that I like to call stage 0 medicine.
And as a cancer doctor, I'm looking forward to being out of a job.
Thanks very much.
(Applause)
Host: Thank you. Thank you.
Take a bow, take a bow.